I just got off a call with Joseph
zardoni the guy that runs save future
Stargate travel Facebook page and this
man has serious passion when it comes to
Stargate he has done several of his own
really big passion projects he runs the
Facebook Channel with over 22,000
followers he has been all over my
Twitter for years now and he is one of
the Front Runners the guys really ahead
of the game when it comes to trying to
bring back Stargate and listen for the
end there where there's a bit of a
giveaway he's running over the Christmas
[Music]
period so as you know uh sa future
Stargate travel has been around for like
12 years now how long you been doing
this oh pushing on two and a half years
now okay so yeah uh that's great man and
you've done a great job and I just want
to just touch on a couple of things like
our page has like really been on the
front lines of everything that has to do
with bringing back Stargate I mean you
talk about petitions you talk about
mailings you talk about rins and you
name it the Twitter storm we're on the
front lines and we're like hey man it
we've got to get gate back I mean uh and
and we got a lot of people that agree
with us and I'm glad about that we've
had Roland Emer come and visit us we've
had uh uh David blue we've had other
stars come by and uh I think Brad Wright
owes me owes me a visit I mean I've had
this for 12 years I think the man could
come by for 12 seconds and say Hey Joe
good job I I probably die happy right
there but anyway so I just wanted to get
that out there I think you'll agree with
me that there are a whole lot of
unanswered questions about Stargate that
the fans are just
what the heck we got to know what's
going on right yeah I mean we got 15
years of story we got to tell right I
mean there must be at least two dozen
hardcore questions that big to be
answered and that's one of the reasons I
was doing this I mean of course the the
fate of Eli is just one of many I think
SCU got a bad rep and I want your your
take on this uh every time we had a
transition or it wasn't really one time
before that that was from sg1 to to
Atlantis it was handled beautifully no I
mean they kind of like weaned us on on
board and said hey you know we're
looking for the lost city we're doing
this we're doing that and they talked
about Atlantis and by the time Atlantis
manifested the fans were already like
okay let's go to Atlantis you know but
when it came to Stargate Universe it's
like bam no no more Atlantis and bam
we're on Destiny and it was different
everything about it was different and we
were in Shell Shock and that was unfair
to the actor
and the fans and even my idol uh Joel
Goldsmith who I really do respect so
much changed his Motif too and the music
changed it was just we were all in Shell
Shock and I just wish there was somewh
we can go back in time and fix that but
what Stan has done but do you agree with
me about the transition handled poorly
from from Atlantis to to Universe well I
mean it was a business decision wasn't
it as well at the time and it was MGM in
trouble and I mean this two different
versions of the story because you listen
to Joe Flanigan and Brad's take on it
it's a little bit different but the
general G seems to be all the guys over
at MGM and uh it was on sci-fi at the
time wasn't it I think the networker in
it yeah time um had basically said we
want something new and the new owners at
MGM had come in I think at that point
where it wasn't really the new owners
but like the people that owned the debt
had took over yeah Brad was still
pulling the strings on the whole
production though wasn't he Brad doesn't
really have at the end of the day Brad's
the the the showrunner but he's not the
guy that controls the pur strings so if
the bosses say we want some
different you kind of stuck you got to
do something different so they basically
say look we want a brand new
show uh we want rid of Atlantis there's
one version that says Atlantis wasn't
making money Joe Flanigan says it was
making a load of money so that's
different slightly different variation
of a
theme um but SGU was
definitely I think pressure from above
of people saying we we want something
different we want something that's more
in line with like other shows that were
about at the time that we're making
noise like battar Galactica okay well
even if that's true yeah I think they've
done two shows that were very similar
and I even think from a creative point
of view Brad was probably thinking we
need to we need to do something new we
need to freshen this up we need to think
and it just didn't quite work I'm it
ain't broke don't fix it I mean they
already did a beautiful thing from from
sj1 to Atlantis all right you want to
change it change it but don't leave a
shell shocked and with no heads up about
what's coming up no none of the actors
they could have brought uh uh carile on
as in advance or or Colonel young in
advance let let us meet some of these
characters that we're going to be seeing
in SGU they did not do that no there was
no I don't think there was any real plan
um I mean if you again if you believe
some of the rumors Atlantis found out
they were being cancelled two or three
episodes towards the end I you can kind
of tell from watching the series yes
sort of build it and then all of a
sudden it's like oh we're done yeah I
know that that was just wrong on many
levels as Jack O'Neal watch yeah I
watched Atlantis recently um I I
generally tried to watch him about once
a year just started on S1 again but um I
watch Atlantis recently and it is the
end is jerky it's sort of like man yeah
but you know what I got to say and I've
admitted this on my page it was Atlantis
that really made a gator out of me I
mean I loved uh star gsg1 but when I
seen Atlantis and I got on board with it
I'm like man this is great science
fiction I mean everything about it you
was edge of your seat and White Knuckle
ride I mean you know it was just awesome
and I miss it so much and that is why I
take to the next topic which is Stargate
forever where Atlantis play a major role
in the storyboard production uh Stargate
Universe I'm sure Stargate Universe
sorry Stargate forever yeah Stargate
forever is a tributary Series in the
purest sense and what I mean by that is
that as you know 12 years have passed
and none of us look the same that we did
12 years ago I don't care how many
vitamins you do I don't care how much
you work out no matter what you do for
all the time takes its toll now right
now if they if they signed the papers
right now and got the script right now
and get everything rolling right now
it's G to be another year before we see
anything and that was if they did it
today now you could imagine if they
lolly gag around for another couple of
years how many people are we goingon to
lose to either old age or other acting
commitments or passing on to the other
side we don't know but it's it's a bad
thing that it's taken this long and I
put out a meme can you wait too long to
do the right things and have skeletons
coming out of the gate
I
then if we do arrive safely at the Fri
Galaxy and carry out our rescue and
reconnaissance plans there will be two
more galaxies we will be visiting after
that taking us further and further from
our home you know they could probably do
something like what I've done here with
uh Stargate forever and use AI to like
you know Gussy up the actors a little
bit make them look a little younger I
mean you could you can do a lot now with
AI and with you know all types of video
enhancement so I think it's doable and
if not this story of course you know
Brad Wright has something like this that
was shot down I remember seeing
something along the lines that they
wanted to connect the dots between
Stargate sg1 and Atlantis and universe
and it was shot down and that hurt my
heart I'm like man that's that's what I
wanted to see now this story we got a
movie we got the TV movie that was
supposed to be have all three elements
to it so um which was going to round off
SGU and we we came that close to getting
that um
he was like three or four three or four
weeks into writing when they sort of
went can you do it for this money no can
you do it for a bit less money no you do
and then it sort of got pulled but he he
started writing it um
so I don't know what they were thinking
but I mean money they didn't have any
that's what they were thinking they
didn't have didn't have the money so
they say but you know what uh once they
sold to Amazon I'm like well they can't
say they don't have the money now now
because Amazon could could Fork over
half a billion dollars and not even feel
it you know so whole thing of uh not
having the money to do it right goes out
the window things involved
here I think we've got a little bit to
in hindsight now I look back on a year
ago and we thought well this will happen
really
quickly if you actually look at even and
they haven't announced any of the major
MGM projects that they were hoping to do
RoboCop hasn't been announced Legally
Blonde 3 hasn't even been announced and
that is officially in early production
before Amazon bought it right so
nothing's been announced I think it is
the thing of MGM had to be massively
restructured and absorbed into Amazon
and that took a long time um I get to
talk to people that work over at MGM and
I know that the the the changes in
management structure and everything has
been massive they've had to hire a bunch
of new people which they've only just
they only just hired ahead of production
films which was like three or three
months ago or something and it was only
just March just gone that the head of
film in claudo Valentini was hired so I
mean they've had to restructure all of
this stuff so they haven't actually
announced anything don't have ducks in a
row yet they they're not in the row but
then the strikes happened yeah well that
happened I they were expecting the
writers to go but they w't apparently
when the writers went they weren't
expecting the actors to go they thought
they had a decent deal for the actors
and then the actors went as well was
like
Jesus I've actually a little bit of an
update I've spoken about um how Amazon
had a bit of a up with um getting
restarted again so when the actors went
back and the writers went back they
didn't have enough Studio space to
restart the projects they they'd already
started before the strikes right um but
apparently that's sorted now now pretty
much and in the new year they will be
able to at very least get the stuff
they'd already started
restarted and then hopefully they'll be
able to start thinking about new stuff
yeah well I don't see how they could not
consider Brad Wright who had 17 well at
least 15 successful seasons of Stargate
and millions of fans worldwide that love
him I don't know who at the top is
saying I don't think he's right for the
job who who in the world would think
like that
now
jennif Jaz if you're listening Brad
Wright is your man if not him Roland
Emerick that's it nobody else no please
don't be Roland Emer Roland Emer 20
years ago I I don't think he's the I
don't I I don't think he's done anything
his last two or three projects have not
been for me well no but you got to
remember that if it wasn't for Roland
amerck and Dean develin there would be
no Stargate so at my page and in my
point of view they are royalty because
without them they would never would have
been a Stargate and I think you know he
could probably do something good with it
if you know if not something great I
don't think he would drop the ball on
that one R visually Roland Emer still
does amazing things so and I mean if you
brought him with Dean delin who I still
think does he's a brilliant writer so
maybe he's a team but yeah I just want
to point say one other thing about
Roland em before we get away from him
and that is that I heard a lot of things
that he hates sg1 he hates and I went on
a crusade to look for any snippet
whether it's an in print or video of him
saying that he hated it and the only
thing he said he hated was the money
they offered him to do sg1 that was it
he never said he hat that was never true
as far as I know yeah right but a lot of
people that was a rumor that went around
that Roland Emer hates Stargate sg1 he
doesn't he probably I think that came
from um that Brad Wright sort of like
offered a hand that and he said would
you know could we collaborate on how I'm
going to restart this en roll and S of
went no that's I've got my I've got
other stuff I've done this I've done
Stargate I'm going to move on now but I
don't think that was I I hate sg1 it was
more a it wasn't um it was his baby he
wasn't gonna hate on it yeah all right
getting back to uh Stargate for I'm
trying to rush ahead because I know you
have to leave for work soon so I
wna uh I want to say that I put a lot a
lot of hours into creating Stargate
forever I mean it it near killed me I
made sacrifices it started out as just
something that was kind of cool and then
I got more Ser by the second EP second
installment I I was all all in and by
the third one I said I got to do
something that really represents and I
think I I well I know you listen to it
did you see it also yeah no I watched it
yeah okay cool what did you think you
could be honest if you didn't like it I
could take it no I loved it I mean the
main thing is like you said about how it
nearly killed you I can see why that I I
do a bit of editing and myel and uh that
must have took you
forever I thought it was awesome and
it's just it's all one of those things
that's just keeping the and I will add
links to it in the description you guys
can go and check it out yourselves I I
could tell your viewers up front uh if
you watch the first one you don't like
it you could probably stop right there
even though it does get better if it's
not your thing you're expecting to see
like cool explosions and the real
actress no it's not that okay uh the
only AI that was done was for the voices
and everything else was hand animated
hand pasted and the script is 100%
totally me it was a oneman project done
with zero budget so and I think I came
up with something re the real reason I I
did it was once I found out that Amazon
turned down Brad I'm like we're not
getting Stargate this is what we should
have had you know 10 years ago and I
went ah had and then I had to like
rewrite it a little bit because the
story that I wrote for 10 years ago
didn't really apply anymore you know
like Todd had been locked up for now A
Dozen Years and that's mentioned in the
series and now he's he's kind of like
one of us now he's he's an Earthling now
and people love Todd and people love to
know what the heck happened to Atlanta
it's certainly not as in San Francisco
Bay anymore what happened to it we kind
of touch on that
so the reviews project anything that
keeps Stargate and the love for Stargate
going I'm on board with and the love for
Stargate screams through your project so
I mean tell Darren Sumer that out of
gate world because I I contacted him a
couple of times oh I haven't gotone
around to look at it yet okay then a
couple a couple of months went by get to
the second one oh no I'm gonna get to it
and I just you know what I I don't think
he wants to like touch on fanfiction or
maybe he just doesn't like me that could
be possible because I kind of like
bugged him to be part of the Twitter
storm and he got mad at me at that and
that's cool but D they don't like
getting involved in things like that
yeah well I can understand that but this
is something slightly different because
see I have a unique set of skills I I
want a scholarship for creative writing
and uh I also uh I've been a lifelong
musician so I was able to actually
enhance some of Joel gold Smith's music
and include some original scores uh I've
been involved in video editing now for a
couple years because my daughter is
gonna be putting out a country video
soon and so I had to like sharpen my
video skills and then I've done some
animation too which I was really proud
of the super bad guys's uh hand behind
the tree which was like really cool to
do you know the super should I say the
name of the super bad guys or should I
let them find out you you can do
whatever you want CH oh thank
you the more
to see you in a wee be L I'm headed for
the med lab to make sure all is secure
for the jump see
you they are
called the more
to they are super bad guys man I mean
like just when you think you got away
from the drones and you're you're aboard
Destiny and you think everything's going
to be cool when you wake up it's not and
that's all I'm going to say about that
but yeah the reviews have been so kind I
mean if you go before you even want to
your viewers before you even watch the
first one just read a little bit through
and see because you can lose patience
really easy on something like that oh
that's with this I don't want to see no
give it a chance with just a little bit
of imagination you will feel like you're
watching the Stargate that we should
have had 10 years ago that was my intent
when I Creed it and I did it more more
along the lines just so I could watch it
and then when I did I said you know what
I think a lot of people would like this
you know and so the super bad guys are
cool and and Todd is cool and the whole
series turned out to be really good and
I really don't want to do another one
but if we if we're here one year from
now and we still haven't got a solid
word on when the new Stargate is coming
out I'll have to do an episode
two and we if we if we haven't got
something by this time next year I I
would put it down to we ain't getting
anything for years so yeah Do It
um we've got right now the next couple
of months might be interesting because
apparently there's a conversation still
going on MGM about MGM want to do a
series basically and Amazon want to do a
movie and right Amazon have been
listening to MGM and there were
discussions a couple of months ago but
we don't know what the answer was to the
discussions what the so mg went so
basically Amazon went okay you keep
arguing about a series what the argument
what the what tell me and they listened
but I don't know what the answer was to
the meeting s thing I only know the
meeting happened um MGM puts
its um development list out in the end
of January early February so if they won
the argument and we're going to get a
series before the movie it'll be on that
list if it isn't on that list then it'll
be a movie in which case it'll be I'm
being told possibly the summer until we
get an announcement it'll be San Diego
ComiCon next that's really it be a movie
time man that is long time we've already
waited so long we gonna wait till
another seven months it'll be June next
year that mean we're looking at
2025 best case you say it's a movie
probably early 2026 now I mean oh God
apparently the San Diego Comic Con 2023
plan was for a movie that was supposed
to start it was going to be announced in
June it was supposed to start filming
late summer um and then it would
basically from filming takes about 18
months so the idea was for spring 2025
that's basically been pushed back a year
so it'll be uh spring summer
2026 if they do a
movie that's just too much I don't know
if I can handle it anyway this this
little this little uh story book series
that I created helps me handle helps me
deal with it and uh I want to let your
VI viewers know that um one week from
tomorrow uh next Saturday night at 800
PM uh Eastern Standard time we're going
to have a little contest and I'm going
to give away one of these shirts or 35
bucks if the because we're worldwide now
we got people from all over the world
logging into safe future Stargate travel
and some of the last time I had a ship
one of these overseas it was ridiculous
it was like $70 to ship a t-shirt I'm
like I ain't doing that that's crazy so
you'll either win one of these t-shirts
and if if the shipping is reasonable or
or 35 bucks through PayPal so I wanted
to get that out there and uh I also want
to ask you did you see your name in the
credits at at the end of
uh what at the end of at the end of the
series I probably didn't watch the
credits if I'm
honest I mean we got quite a long video
Joe I mean I might I might have zoned
out of the credits I know I told you if
I hit the Powerball I'll go to MJ and
say look I I'll fund this and I want
Brad to run with it okay so since I'm
paying for it you let Brad run it and
you just stay out of it and let him do
it Brad has his allies at MGM so it's
not
impossible um I mean I was the it was my
channel that dropped first that he
wasn't going to be involved so even
though I got blamed for that quite a lot
all sorts of names y sorry how' you get
blamed for that I don't know some people
seem to want to blame the messenger uh
he's a liar he's making stuff up there's
no way they wouldn't go with Brad a year
later told you um but anyway um but he
has got friends at MGM people like M mm
plus I hope they stand their ground and
say look anybody else other than him or
sorry Roland you shouldn't even consider
you got somebody else that you you're
running with you better think twice
because the fans probably aren't going
to like it unless it's spectacular and
connects all the dots that we're
familiar with Joe thank you so much bud
for for popping on and all the work you
do and actually your channel I say your
YouTube channel your sorry and your
Facebook channel has supported Sid trk
as well more than once so I I thank you
for that well we have and this will this
will go on there like assuming you
release it it's going to go on there so
thank you very much thank you very much
right chck merry Christmas happy New
Year and to all my gator friends God
bless you all Merry Christmas and happy
New Year and keep the faith we're GNA
get this done somehow happy holidays Joe
adios my
[Music]
friend